[Musique]
bienvenue à la une de paris saclay tv la
ligne 18 après une année 2010 8 riche en
actualité elle est enfin sur les rails
nos conventions foncière a été signé
entre le pea paris saclay et la société
du grand paris
vous entendrez thierry d'allah c'est le
président du directoire de la société du
grand paris
la mobilité sur votre territoire c'est
aussi mobile app ce bâtiment vient
d'être inauguré il accueillera à cluster
de mobilité innovante et tout de suite
un exemple concret de cette mobilité
innovante avec framboise litchi de
navettes s'envolant conducteur c'est une
première en france
et cela se passe sur votre territoire
vous pour essayer aussi c'est plus
classique jouve premier service de
partage de vélos électriques respectueux
de la voie publique
le système est ingénieux nous verrons
comment enfin nous reviendrons sur meet
my plateforme journée dédiée aux
sciences de la vie la première édition a
eu lieu juste dernières mois à centrale
supélec enfin à notre agenda
ce sera à la fin cette émission
la ligne 18 est sur les rails elle
devrait être livrée dans un premier
temps en 2026 ce métro de 35 km va
desservir dean gares entre l'aéroport
d'orly et versa chantier il passera par
massy palaiseau et le plateau de saclay
le pea paris saclay a signé une
convention foncière avec la société du
grand paris et nous avons rencontré
thierry dallas il est à la tête du
directoire de la société du grand paris
[Musique]
cette convention est là principalement
pour objectif de coordonner les
acquisitions foncières des deux
établissements publics engagés tous les
deux sur le même territoire l'un pour
réaliser la ligne 18 et l'autre vont
réaliser les aménagements qui vont
concrétiser le développement sur sur le
plateau dont il était vraiment important
qu'on puisse définir la méthodologie et
puis les modes de détention des terrains
puisque l'objectif de ce grand paris
c'est de pouvoir notamment restituer à
l'établissement public
ceux qui n'auront pas été utilisé pour
réaliser métro et les premières dates
sont celles qui a donné le premier
ministre dans sa feuille de route au
mois de février dernier rappelle que
l'objectif de réalisation de la ligne 18
en totalité d'orly jusqu'à versailles
c'est 2030 avec une échéance de 2027
pour la mise en service entre orly et sa
clique que nous avons proposé c'est de
réaliser une mise en service anticipée
sur la section où la sous section entre
massy palaiseau donc au niveau de la
station du rer jusqu'à saclay avec un
horizon de 2026 donc les appels d'offres
qui sont en cours notamment le premier
lot de génie civil qui est l'un des
trois principaux lots de cette ligne est
en cours de consultation dans cette
perspective là et ce marché devrait
pouvoir être signés tout début de
l'année prochaine de deux millions en
2019 et 2020 vont être effectivement des
années principalement consacrée au
lancement des marchés
il aura évidemment des travaux mais des
travaux préparatoires qui s'inscrivent
depuis quasiment lankais public et le
décret d'utilité publique de 2017 afin
justement de préparer l'arrivée
l'arrivée des chantiers principaux les
travaux préparatoires c'est quoi c'est
enlever et déplacer les les réseaux
divers et variés des concessionnaires en
dehors de l'endroit où vous allez avoir
par exemple gare ou un ouvrage annexes
en 2019
il y aura un lancement important c'est
ce de marché c'est celui du matériel
roulant
je rappelle que mattel roulant et une 18
est légèrement différent de celui qui a
été attribué l'an dernier pour les
lignes 15 16 et 17
que donc c'est dire est ce ce marché
donc l'appel d'offres sera lancé au
printemps après matérialise une de
manière assez concrète le caractère
irréversible de ce projet on n'achète
pas du matériel roulant si on ne fait
pas le projet
les autres marchés qui vont venir il y
en a un sur un site particulièrement
parce que c'est celui qui finalement va
va être déterminant pour le calendrier
de 2030 pour la mise en scène jusqu'à
versailles c'est tout le génie civil de
saint-quentin devant le golf national
jusqu'à la gare de versailles
l'objectif c'est de pouvoir signer ce
contrat au premier trimestre 2009 1 2
avec un lancement d'appels d'offres qui
pourraient être lancés fin fin 2020
voilà les principales dates en matière
de calendrier
cette ligne 18 desservira à terme le
plus grand centre de recherche et de
développement d'europe
un exemple parmi d'autres le mobile app
qui accueille à versailles-satory un
cluster de mobilité innovantes
ce site vient tout juste d'être inauguré
connaissez-vous framboise et litchi ces
deux navettes roule sans conducteur ni
volant c'est une première en france
et cela se passe sur le territoire
[Musique]
le but c'était de données que vous avez
du plateau de satory eau est une autre
alternative pour pouvoir se mouvoir
cette alternative à les données par les
navettes automne aux framboises et
litchi ses navettes et sont accessibles
à tous à tous les usagers à tous les
visiteurs et les salariés du 2 du
plateau ce service et ses navettes du
congo notamment desservir plusieurs
arrêts l'art et nexter l'arrêt psa
motorsport l'arrêt arcus et enfin le
mobile à bhl qui a tout d'abord une
application qui va permettre de
géolocaliser les navettes et donc de
pouvoir également donc les commandes et
il va y avoir également un steward qui
va être à bord et qui va permettre
notamment de pouvoir guider les
différents usagers ce nouveau mode de
transport et enfin la navette l équipé
de plusieurs éléments plusieurs capteurs
qui permettent de la géolocaliser et
également d'assurer un service et un
transport en toute sécurité
l'objectif c'est également d'avoir une
perception est tendu donc de permettre
de voir ce qu'un conducteur classique ne
verrez pas à savoir des caméras qui vont
par exemple être placés à différents
endroits et qui vont être connectés avec
la navette lui permettant d'adapter son
comportement en fonction de ce qui
arrivera il y aura également des feux
connectés donc tout un ensemble de
dispositifs sur le bord de route qui va
améliorer le service
enfin c'est une expérience qui va durer
18 mois et qui va permettre de
comprendre les usages et donc les
comportements des usagers par rapport à
ces nouveaux modes de service vous
pouvez aussi faire comme vous mettre au
vélo voici jouve premier service de
partage de vélos à assistance électrique
il se met en place sur le plateau de
saclay et si vous redoutez l'anarchie
sur les trottoirs et bien soyez rassurés
tout a été fait tout a été pensé pour le
stationnement de ces deux roues le
système est un génie regardez
[Musique]
ouf c'est une société qui cherche à
développer l'usagé du vélo pour offrir
une alternative crédible à la voiture
personnelle
donc pour ça on est parti du principe
qu'il faut faciliter le déploiement des
services de vélos électriques partager
et donc on a vu des modèles très
intéressant arrivé depuis un peu plus
d'un an et demi avec des vélos sans
station c'est un modèle qui est
intéressant par la rapidité de
déploiement mais qui créent du désordre
dans les villes donc chez ouvre on a
inventé un nouveau type de stationnement
qui fonctionnent comme les caddies de
supermarché il ya une première borne
convient vissé dans le sol
et puis ensuite chaque vélo s'accroche
au vélo précédent le premier vélo
s'accrochant la borne ça nous permet de
mettre quatre vélos au m donc c'est une
solution qui est très compact en étant à
la fois très léger en termes
d'infrastructures puisqu'on a juste
cette première borne à venir glisser
dans le sol ça nous permet de lancer
facilement sans demander d'argent à la
collectivité c'est nous qui supporte le
coût de l'installation de ces stations
et d'autre une seule station pour
structurer le parking dans les lieux
danse ça chante dans les lieux moins
dense sur lesquels on peut se permettre
de garer les vélos sans station on va le
permettre
et c'est via l'application mobile qu'on
va explique à l'utilisateur quand est-ce
qu'il doit remettre le vélo en station
quand est ce qui peut laisser le vélo
hors stations et si ça ça génère du
désordre de manière évolutive on pourra
venir
introduire de nouvelles stations pour
structurelles parking on a choisi le
plateau de saclay pour plusieurs raisons
la première d'entre elles c'est la
proximité géographique avec notre siège
social qui est basée à vendre la seconde
c'est que c'est un territoire qui
présente une grande diversité d'usagés
puisqu'il ya des entreprises
les écoles des collectivités donc on a
on a tous types d'utilisateurs ce qui
nous intéresse évidemment pour une phase
de test et puis enfin c'est un
territoire qui cherche à gagner en
visibilité qui se développe sur lequel
il ya un manque de solutions de mobilité
donc il nous paraissait pertinents a
adressé comme le lancement produit
l'assistance électrique est quand même
un atout tout à fait appréciable pour
pour les gens qui viennent travailler
donc pas forcément sportif et qui
souhaitent accéder au plateau de sacrée
d'une manière un peu plus durable que
parler
que par les véhicules donc moi je le
teste depuis quelques jours on découvre
un petit peu le plateau aussi d'une
autre façon donc moi je connais très
bien ce plateau est là le fait de le
parcourir à vélo ça fait découvrir des
voilà des choses un petit peu nouvelles
des points de vue un petit peu différent
et tout ça dans d'excellentes conditions
cette phase d'expérimentation condé fois
sur le plateau de saclay donc avec 200
vélos à peu près 12 stations qui sont
déployées auprès de grandes entreprises
comme thales le cea l'onera des écoles
comme centrale supélec va nous permettre
d'accumuler des retours utilisateurs
d'améliorer le produit de mettre en
place nos process ceci pendant toute une
durée de cinq mois suite à quoi nous
pourrons travailler sur notre lancement
commercial dans le courant de la nuit
on s'arrête maintenant sur cet événement
meet my plate forme événement organisé
par le département sciences évite de
l'université paris saclay et par
genopole l'idée est de créer une
plateforme sur ces vies et de provoquer
des rencontres dans ce domaine c'était
la première édition et ça s'est passé et
si
[Musique]
nous sommes heureux du succès de cette
première journée huit mâles plateforme
qui est réalisé à centrale supélec
première journée dédiée aux plateformes
technologiques de sciences de la vie que
j'ai nopal organisé depuis cinq années
consécutives et fort de cette expérience
nous nous sommes rapprochés du
département sciences de la vie de
l'université paris saclay pour mettre en
place cette journée qui a dédié donc aux
plateformes technologiques dans le
domaine des sciences de la vie et
notamment pour créer des interactions
entre les académiques et les industriels
de l'atome technologique c'est le
regroupement à un endroit unique de
compétences savoir faire et
d'équipements à la pointe de la
technologie dans le domaine des sciences
de la vie
[Musique]
ce département regroupe aujourd'hui 200
plateforme technologique un grand nombre
sont affiliés à des organismes de
recherche certaines au genopole le
programme de la journée comprend
plusieurs actes le premier acte était
d'une introduction faite par le
directeur du département sciences de la
vie puis par un acteur du génopole le
deuxième acte était une table ronde où
trois industriels renommée est bien
connu 2
monde industriel se sont présentés
servier danone est hantée rome l'acte
iii était une présentation des
typologies des plus importantes de ces
plateformes comme l'imagerie on la
génomique et le quatrième acte est ce
que vous voyez derrière moi savoir tous
ces stands avec le 84 plateforme
présente des industriels présents cet
après midi on laisse la place aux
plateformes technologiques pour qu'elles
puissent rencontrer les autres plates
formes du territoire qu'elles puissent
créer une vraie communauté sur paris
saclay des plateformes sciences de la
vie et on invite également des
industriels à venir les rencontrer pour
ouvrir un peu ses plateformes et donner
accès à leur expertise à ses industriels
donc on en a plus de 30 sont présents
aujourd'hui
donc aujourd'hui c'est libre cours à ses
plateformes en espérant que les échanges
soient productifs nous en tout cas côté
université paris saclay genopole on n'en
doute pas et on est très fiers
d'accueillir tout ce monde aujourd'hui
[Musique]
notre agenda à présent on commence avec
une exposition sur le sont un phénomène
familier et pourtant peu connue en
acoustique un monde de vibrations c'est
jusqu'au 24 février au château du val
fleuri à gif sur yvette
l'entrée est libre et gratuite
maintenant je m'adresse aux plus
sportifs d'entre vous ne ratez pas le
night and day paris saclay 2019 c'est le
1er et 2 mars 2010neuf donc venez
découvrir la vallée de chevreuse
sportivement le night and day saclay
c'est d'abord un trail de nuit ça c'est
le vendredi puis une journée en vtt
trail course d'orientation vous on vous
attend aussi à la fête des entrepreneurs
il ya des conférences des business
meetings et bien sûr une grande soirée
c'est le 20 mars à l'opéra de massy de
16 heures à 18 heures c'est gratuit mais
il faut réserver
autre événement le design spot invite la
designer constance guisset et le
mathématicien mark schwahn hour pour un
entretien hors des sentiers battus on va
parler d'intelligence artificielle et de
création c'est le 21 mars à palaiseau
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
vous retrouverez toutes les informations
sur notre site pap.fr a très vite
[Musique]
oui